Welcome back to the show, we did have that
rare very last minute guest cancelation today.
I think we can say maybe partially related
to Corona virus, although I guess we're not
completely sure right now.
But as a result, we're going to just take
a few phone calls.
It was impossible to find a replacement guest
on short, short notice.
So let's go right to the phones and start
with our caller from the 6 0 3 area code 6
0 3, possibly our is 6 or 0 3.
And New Hampshire.
Is that.
Is that it?
Yes, it is.
Lucky him, you do?
Yes, I can.
A great yeah, that is an answer.
I said two quick, very quick comments.
First questions I want to be feedback on.
The first is the bosbach rotavirus, unfortunately.
Well, my first thing is I agree with you.
You've said for the most part, obviously Trump's
handling has been pretty, pretty absurd.
But the thing I keep hearing is that earlier
action would have been better if we had shut
things down quicker, if we had banned travel
quicker.
Whatever.
It just seems like that's a little bit unfair
because of course, that's true.
You know, you can always look back and say
we should've done stuff more seriously, taken
take a more swift action.
It's just hardly seems like an insight to
me.
I feel like at the time, if we had done more
drastic action, you know, shutting down the
economy, banning all travel and trying to
something like that back in January would
have seemed like an overreaction.
You know, it just seems very difficult to
know how things would have played out on some
frisky reaction on on that.
Just just feeling like it's almost total logical
to say, well, listen.
You're right about one thing, which is it
is always much easier to Monday morning quarterback.
And in retrospect, it all seems so much clearer.
So on the specifics of saying travel obviously
should have been banned much earlier.
It's not the fairest criticism.
But the truth is that by the time Trump ban
traveled from China, the focus had really
moved to Europe.
And by the time Trump did that, you know,
a lot of people were laid on that.
It wasn't just Trump.
I think the fairer criticism is the things
that weren't done or things that the pandemic
response team would have done, which Trump
disbanded.
And that includes you develop a test much
sooner.
South Korea did it.
South Korea and the U.S. had their first confirmed
case.
Within 24 hours.
South Korea immediately developed a test,
mass tested, isolated and contact traced.
They still don't have 200 deaths and we had
over a thousand deaths yesterday alone.
That's a fair criticism that should have been
done earlier.
The mobilization and plan for the strategic
stockpile, ventilators and masks, etc. Trump
was waylaid on that.
You need to early identify and start mobilizing
those resources.
So the travel ban criticism alone is some
kind of 20/20 hindsight to some degree.
That is not totally fair, but there is such
a longer list of things that should have been
done and would have if the pandemic response
team hadn't been disbanded.
Yep.
No, I totally agree.
I think that's that's very well put.
And it's one very quick other comment.
I think the only other element that seems
like a little bit of an unfair criticism,
but again, just want to get your take on it.
But that said, there it just relates to the
ventilators and the stock, thousands of tablet
you mentioned.
I mean, you know, we all know Bill Gates give
that said talk on how unprepared the system
was for a pandemic back in 2015.
And obviously, Trump's just blaming Obama.
It's actually just kind of a political stunt
on Obama's fault.
It's kind of every president, I guess you
could say, leading up to this point.
But it does seem like that's something that
doesn't come into play.
I mean, you know, the US as a whole, the federal
governments are very unprepared for something
like this, managed from the federal level.
We obviously have a very bad leader in charge
now to be handling it.
But it also seems like, you know, again, that's
just the other criticism I see that sometimes
I see laid out very unfairly.
Say something like, how did Trump not know,
you know, and keep the stockpile so low?
That also doesn't seem fair.
So for somebody to take on that, then that's
it.
Well, again, I think that the size of the
stockpile is 5 percent of the criticism, 95
percent is getting rid of the pandemic response
team, not having a team in place to start
strategically thinking about growing the stockpile
starting in December and mobilizing the stockpile
where now you have states making requests.
Some states get requests filled, some don't.
So the size of the stockpile alone is only
about 5 percent of the criticism.
Even if you say that it's completely unfair.
That still leaves another 95 percent.
Sure, sure.
All right, thank you so much for the call,
I really appreciate it.
Great to hear from our friends, our friendly
neighbors to the north, northwest, north.
I guess in in New Hampshire.